[Música]
una defensa de la polémica reforma de
las pensiones y un nuevo llamado al
diálogo eso fue lo que hizo el
presidente francés Emmanuel majó este
lunes al dar su primer discurso desde
que promulgó la ley que elevará la edad
de retiro de 62 a 64 años entre otras
medidas sin embargo el país sigue
dividido y los sindicatos convocaron a
una movilización masiva para el primero
de mayo mahón afirmó que escucho a los
manifestantes y que entiende su ira pero
intenta pasar la página trazando una
nueva hoja de ruta y prometiendo 100
días de acción al servicio de Francia
escuchemos parte de lo que dijo
diferente esta ira que se ha expresado
debemos actuar de manera aún más
vigorosa por eso he propuesto recibir a
las organizaciones Patronales Y
sindicales a partir de mañana por la
mañana para los que quieran hacerlo la
puerta siempre estará abierta Y eso para
abrir sin ningún límite sin ningún tabú
una serie de negociaciones en torno a
temas esenciales mejorar de los
asalariados hacer progresar las carreras
compartir mejor las riquezas mejorar las
condiciones de trabajo encontrar
soluciones para el desgaste profesional
aumentar el trabajo de las personas
mayores y ayudar a las reconversiones
este nuevo pacto de la vida en el
trabajo se construirá en las próximas
semanas a través del diálogo social y a
través de acuerdos muy concretos a nivel
nacional y también más cerca del terreno
Este es el tema que vamos a analizar hoy
en el debate para ello invitamos a
Pascal analista político y especialista
en relaciones internacionales quien está
en París también nos acompaña flojeran
la fax ex consejero del gobierno entre
2015 y 2017 y actual Vocero del partido
de izquierda la federación progresista
movimiento que se opuso a la reforma él
está en la paz Bolivia antes le quiero
recordar a nuestros televidentes que
también hacen parte de este debate dejen
sus comentarios y todas las preguntas
que tengan a través de las redes
sociales nos encuentran en Twitter
Facebook e Instagram como arroba franz24
raya al piso es pueden comentar con la
etiqueta numeral el debate f24 y a mí me
encuentran en redes sociales como arroba
María cl Aguirre no olviden que todos
los contenidos de nuestro programa están
disponibles en Apple podcast Spotify
deezer y TuneIn
quiero comenzar entonces dándole la
bienvenida a Pascal
Cuál es su impresión del discurso que
dio Emmanuel majón
Hola María Clara pues era un discurso
que estaba una locución que estaba
espirada creo que Emmanuel hoy quiso
marcar su tiempo como han dicho definió
un periodo de cien días dando cita para
el 14 de Julio cien días para definir
tres orientaciones el trabajo lo que
llamó
el este Pilar de trabajo el pilar
justicia
y orden republicano y el progreso es
decir que definió tres orientaciones
orientaciones globales en un tiempo
definido de 10 de 100 días para reanudar
un diálogo definitivamente Y
definir un nuevo impulso para
periodo presidencial estamos al final
del primer año de un mandato de cinco
años un final de año que se acabó con
una reforma que generó una contestación
social definitivamente Y por cierto para
Emmanuel macco la meta hoy en día es dar
un nuevo impulso en un contexto
particular en el cual no tiene mayoría
absoluta en el parlamento y en el cual
pues después de esa fase de contestación
debe dar un nuevo vigor a su acción
definiendo entonces esos tres Pilares en
un momento político de política interna
no hablamos obviamente de ropa y de
política exterior entonces fue un
momento importante no es determinante
pero para él importante dando una
orientación con un momento definido en
el espacio del tiempo cien días Pascal
como ustedes bien lo explica macron
trazó los tres frentes en los que
trabajar Durante los próximos cuatro
años de su gobierno Le quiero preguntar
a flojean si opina que estos tres
frentes el trabajo la justicia y el
progreso responden o no a las
manifestaciones en contra de la Reforma
de las pensiones
no Bueno buenas a todos Yo creo que de
todas formas él tenía que hablar después
de dos meses de William que fueron
huelgas duras tenía que tomar la palabra
Y definir un poco la línea y explicar el
Por qué ha hecho en esta decisión de
hacer una reforma sobre la la pensión y
también justificar el uso de cuarenta y
nueve tres y justificar también el Por
qué sureformando fue entendida pero
concretamente lo que es interesante en
todo eso es lo que él no ha anunciado Y
entonces dentro de de algunas cosas que
podían esperar un poco los manifestantes
que no hubo disolución de la asamblea no
hay cambio de gobierno no hay su propia
división obviamente ni un cambio de
primer administral lo que hubiera podido
significar un nuevo paso una nueva
página para esta presidencia y entonces
una nueva era política un nuevo una
nueva meta digamos
entonces lo que él anunció dentro de
estos son muchas fórmulas y pocas
acciones concretas dentro de esto
efectivamente está la la el objetivo de
reforzar el sistema de salud en
particular en el sistema de de
emergencias de los hospitales lo que
puede sorprender porque saliendo
justamente de la de la crisis covid ya
fue
expuesto como una prioridad nacional Y
nuevamente regresamos con este tema
después está el tema de reforzar el
sistema educativo con una alza de Los
sueldos de los profesores eso no tiene
nada nuevo ya fue anunciado hace un mes
y medio Y nuevamente lo ponen este
discurso sinceramente yo no entiendo
porque lo pone como un nuevo objetivo
para estos cien días y después está
evidentemente reforzar el estado de
derecho empleando más magistrados y más
policías pero aquí también aparte de
hacer un anuncio hacia la derecha quizás
para intentar una nueva alianza con el
partido de derecha no veo bien la
explicación del Por qué ha hecho estos
cuatro anuncios que sinceramente pueden
parecer más anecdóticos que otra cosa
pero entonces Le quiero preguntar a
Pascal teniendo en cuenta esto que nos
Explica florean cómo supuestamente el
presidente está escuchando a los
manifestantes porque en su alocución
veíamos que reconocía la rabia de
quienes han protestado durante tres
meses y a su vez defendía la reforma
como necesaria argumentando el déficit
que según cifras del gobierno francés
traen pérdidas de 13.500 millones de
euros cada año de aquí a 2030 y es bajo
ese argumento que el presidente ha
defendido la idea de subir dos años la
edad de retiro y subir además dos años
para recaudar dinero y necesitar este
tiempo para que las personas se puedan
jubilar con todo esto y hablando de
otros sistemas y otras re distintas como
las que menciona florián a la educación
a la salud está escuchando entonces o no
las manifestaciones Pascal
pues obviamente habló Entonces sí habló
es como bien dijo el presidente en sus
primeros minutos de alocución huyó
obviamente
las los manifestantes primero segundo no
se contesta a un momento tan fuerte tan
político con un catálogo no estamos ahí
ordenando en internet una medida que
pueda satisfacer fulano o tal etcétera
no es un catálogo se trata de redefinir
Hacia dónde vamos
redefinir hasta incluso hablando de
trabajo de la base democrática
republicana tanto como de Progreso
empezar a redefinir la noción de
contratos Social es decir participar es
así que lo entendí participar de
redefinición de Francia del tejido
social del tejido económico de Francia Y
seguramente en Nueva fase en próxima
fase lo va a abrir al ámbito obviamente
europeo e internacional creo que
entonces estamos en etapas en fases en
fases de reanudar el hilo primero
segundo
redefinir una una ruta una hoja de ruta
tomando en cuenta tanto el nivel de
contestación que hubo sobre esa reforma
y explicó Por qué era indispensable
realizarla además echando de menos el
hecho de que no hubo Como dijo consenso
sobre dicha reforma pero también pues
reconstruir unas bases y con una etapa
la etapa como dije dentro de cien días
pero quisiera volver un poco a lo que
dijo florián porque aquí estamos en gran
mezcla de todo Estamos hablando de una
reforma de pensiones que tiene que ver
una reforma de institución Porque hablar
de disolución Porque hablar de dimisión
de presidente no es el tema pero
justamente hablar de eso demuestra la
dificultad política en la cual estamos
donde se está mezclando y donde Por
cierto la violencia que quiso
desbordar el movimiento cívico de las
contestaciones tenía esa vocación crear
a fomentar
hacer lo posible para que de la crisis
política volvamos a una crisis
instituciones que no tiene nada que ver
con la reforma de pensiones Entonces
estamos en un momento de verdad es un
momento político importante Y por cierto
el presidente pues lo contesta
redefiniendo Pilares de política interna
que toquen a la temática social a la
temática económica y obviamente pues en
un momento en el cual la inflación está
presente en el cual el poder de vida es
céntrico para millones de franceses Sí
usted nos dice que no se responde a esta
crisis con un catálogo de medidas que
poco o nada tienen que ver con la
reforma de las pensiones sin embargo es
una estrategia que el presidente bajón
ha utilizado en ocasiones anteriores por
ejemplo en diciembre de 2008 de 2018
cuando las protestas de los chalecos
amarillos Ya cumplían un mes el
presidente macron reconoció que había
personas que no estaban siendo
escuchadas un argumento bastante similar
al que está haciendo ahora y respondió
aumentando el salario mínimo en 100
euros a partir del año siguiente y en
junio de 2021
algo Bastante similar luego de que su
partido Renacimiento fuera uno de los
grandes perdedores de las elecciones
municipales y macron anunció una
convención ciudadana por el clima para
elegir a 150 ciudadanos que le
colaborarían a Francia con las políticas
ambientales Es decir de nuevo cambiando
totalmente de tema y ahora el presidente
dice que quiere pasar la página de las
pensiones para enfocarse en otras
materias florián le servirá esta
estrategia al gobierno de macron no yo
creo que es bastante complicado de hecho
el primer problema sobre esta reforma es
que no fue el momento adecuado para
hacer este tipo de reforma sobre
pensiones en un momento que la mayor
parte de la población está justamente
como nos decía mi colega enfrentando una
inflación bastante importante y que ve
su poder adquisitivo reduciéndose a lo
largo de los meses eso es un primer
punto y es por eso también que quizás
vemos parte de la movilización que
bajando por la imposibilidad de toda
esta gente de estar manifestando
protestando todos los días Eso es Es un
Punto Segundo creo que lo importante que
hay que subrayar es el pecado original
del macroismo que es la falta de campaña
en el momento de las legislativas macron
hubiera tenido normalmente obtener una
mayoría en el parlamento una mayoría
completa más del 50% lo que no fue el
resultado que salió de las urnas por
falta de campaña y también por falta de
un programa yo diría ambicioso no
entonces ahí estamos en una esquema
dentro de la asamblea que tenemos una
mayoría relativa que es muy reducida y
que entonces le obliga siempre a tener
que negociar con tal partido a la
izquierda o tal partido a la derecha
para tener una mayoría y hacer votar
ciertas reformas lo que no fue posible
justamente en el momento de la Reforma
de las pensiones entonces
está bloqueado sobre esta esquema de una
asamblea una mayoría suya muy reducida
lo que no le permita avanzar de hecho lo
que me sorprende es ver también este en
este discurso hablar de los cien días
cuando se habla de los cien días siempre
se habla de los cien días los 100
primeros días de una presidencia lo que
ha anuncian los primeros pasos las
primeras páginas los las primeras metas
y primeras leyes que dan un impulso para
el resto del quinquenato y de la
presidencia Hablar ahora de estos cien
días para mí significa mucho de una
presidencia que está en búsqueda de unas
respuestas por falta de esta mayoría
dentro del parlamento Y que él se siente
debilitado y que no está al nivel del
poder que normalmente la quinta
Constitución le permite obtener Entonces
tenemos un ejecutivo que está buscando
soluciones y que todavía no encuentra y
bueno pequeña colección yo yo no estaba
pidiendo ni la división del primer de la
primera ministrada mía la disolución de
la asamblea solamente está diciendo qué
parte de la de los manifestantes estarán
identificando eso y de hecho yo creo que
con una primera administrada así tan
debilitada Es cierto que esta pregunta
seguramente te dará en el momento
adecuado eh macron ha dicho que veremos
las conclusiones de estos cien próximos
días y de ahí yo creo que posiblemente
se podrá preguntar en la definición y El
reemplazo de la primera ministra Quiero
que profundicemos en un punto que usted
menciona y es esta estrategia de los 100
próximos días que es algo que como usted
lo explica se utiliza para calificar las
primeras acciones cuando comienza la
presidencia una presidencia que ya lleva
un año Esto hace parte un poco de la
estrategia de macron de pasar la página
de la Reforma de las pensiones de nuevo
decir que escucha a todos y hacer un
llamado a la unidad y al diálogo Pascal
él cree que esta estrategia le puede
servir a macron sobre todo para calmar
el descontento que continúa por la
reforma de las pensiones
Ah pero yo no sé por qué debería haber
un modelo
mecánico y florián recuerdo a florián
que me llamo Pascal
sabe perfectamente que en la historia de
las últimas décadas hubo momentos
Durante los cuales recuerdo unos
gobiernos bajo conteo había Donde había
una mayoría relativa etcétera entonces
por qué habría un mecanismo que se
tendría que repetir con cien primeros
días que van a condicionar los cinco
años no estamos primero es el segundo
mandato de Manuel está el poder desde
seis años segundo está en una voluntad
de reformas necesarias y obviamente usa
el tiempo del cual dispone para llevar a
cabo esas reformas que considera Útil
para el país además agregaría que la
reforma de las pensiones no es una
novedad lo anunció durante la campaña
presidencial del año pasado recuerdo a
florián que fue elegido el año pasado sí
la mayoría de los franceses no querían
que Manuel mccoy tienen derecho en eso
no fuese elegido pues había que votar
por otros candidatos Entonces él además
el año pasado durante la presidencial
llamó a una reforma que llevaría la edad
a los 65 años sabemos también que el
tiempo de trabajo en Francia es uno de
los más reducido en la Unión Europea no
quiero
recordar Cuál es la edad de jubilación
en España en Dinamarca dentro de otros
Entonces estamos pues en una voluntad de
actuar de manera definitivamente
pragmática sobre
más esenciales ahora es el presidente
Por cierto Como dijo cuando habló habló
de voluntad de Buscar unidad a la vez
ambición acción y participar de una
aparigacimiento nacional ahora
Obviamente el malestar va a seguir vemos
perfectamente que el próximo Randy de la
contestación Social es el primero de
mayo y parece justamente como momento de
etapa para movilizar
movilizar la contestación el día del
primero de mayo en una simbólica fuerte
pero de ahí definitivamente vamos a
pasar a otros momentos y floriano sa qué
le responde a Pascal con la idea de que
pues los franceses sabían que era una
propuesta de campaña de macron reformar
las pensiones
Bueno yo primero les voy a contestar que
este proyecto de de ley de reforma de
las pensiones ya fue prometido también
en la primera presidencia y de una forma
que era sumamente diferente y que además
tenía casi el consenso con los
sindicatos reformistas
cuyos son esenciales para obtener la
aceptación social de la población aquí
yo creo que el problema más fuerte de
esta de esta reforma es que ha negado el
diálogo social con los sindicatos
reformistas Y estos tres sindicatos han
salido en las calles con nosotros que
son un poco más radicales Y entonces por
eso que tuvimos movimientos muy fuertes
según le diría también que la mayor
parte de los franceses no han votado
para macronunas han votado para macron
en la segunda vuelta para evitar la
candidata de extrema derecha y si se
acuerda bien Pascal también en el
discurso de entronización a nivel máximo
lo había recordado diciendo de que sabía
y había entendido que parte de la
población francesa no lo había elegido
para su programa lo que le daba un deber
de hacer un consenso nacional por este
esta elección que fue un poco
excepcional digamos porque era una
elección entre una republicano y una
persona de extrema derecha que yo estimo
que está fuera de contrato de
republicano segundo lo que la gente no
puede entender y eso es un punto muy
importante y hay que ponerse también al
lugar de la gente que está debilitada
por esta inflación han vivido en un
contexto de defensas de de gastos
públicos muy importantes y que eran
necesarios De hecho yo tengo que
reconocer hizo una una actuación muy
buena en el momento de comida salvando
muchos empleos en el momento pero la
gente vio que era que así una una planta
gratuita no y vemos que últimamente y
también con este discurso cuando dice
que va a emplear Diez mil nuevos
magistrados que va a reforzar el sistema
de salud el sistema escolar eso es
muchos gastos públicos también mientras
que la el sistema de pensiones este
trataba de 10 billones de euros que
encontrar ahí se podía hacer de otras
formas hay contribuciones que
podían impactar a otros actores que a
los trabajadores únicamente Les propongo
que ahora cambiemos de tema partiendo de
algo que dice florián y es usted asegura
que no hubo un diálogo social Frente a
esta reforma pensional y esto ha
suscitado críticas por una supuesta
imposición por parte del gobierno macron
sobre esta ley y parte de esas críticas
tienen que ver con el artículo 49.3 que
está en la Constitución Francesa desde
1958 y que le permite al ejecutivo hacer
pasar una discusión de reforma de ley
sin necesidad de tener el voto de la
asamblea nacional que es la cámara baja
del legislativo francés y en este caso
el presidente y la primera ministra
Elizabeth bone activaron este artículo
49.3 para saltarse el debate final de la
asamblea nacional que era donde no
tenían las mayorías garantizadas Pascal
Le quiero preguntar Entonces si teniendo
esto en cuenta la falta de diálogo y el
artículo 49.3 la reforma de las
pensiones fue una medida impuesta o no
bueno primero para que nuestros oyentes
tengan un poco idea se usó cien veces
desde
1958 que es el año de creación de la
nueva constitución de nuestra República
la quinta República en nuestra historia
francesa con El regreso al poder de
general dugol se usó Entonces ese
artículo como otros instrumentos
parlamentarios y constitucionales
desde entonces primero segundo
habla María Clara del artículo
49.3 que es un artículo de un
dispositivo que permite definitivamente
al poder ejecutivo
a tener una prevalecer en unos debates
que pueden ser bloqueados sobre el
legislativo por qué estamos con esa
lógica porque Francia vivió una
inestabilidad política muy fuerte de
1946 hasta 1958 la cuarta república que
era una República parlamentaria era la
República de los partidos 18 gobiernos
en doce años que aceleraron una
debilidad de Francia que en esa época
tenía que contestar a otros desafíos
dentro de lo cual es la de colonización
entonces para restablecer una cierta o
una estabilidad sí hubo y existen
instrumentos constitucionales pero
rápidamente ese artículo cuarenta y
nueve punto tres desde reforma de hace
unos años no puede ser usado en
cualquier condición puede ser usado
específicamente y solamente sobre
proyectos de ley de financiación sobre
proyectos de finanzas
razón por la cual la reforma de
pensiones fue inscrito Por cierto como
un proyecto rectificatorio de finanzas
de seguro social para poder además
enmarcar el debate Por qué enmarcar bajo
una otro artículo en cuarenta y siete
punto uno que obliga en marca en 50 días
el debate Entonces era porque esa
reforma fue considerada por el poder
ejecutivo como una reforma esencial
ahora todo eso rápidamente lo tenemos
que enmarcar en un período
floreal recordó el período de la comida
diecinueve durante dos años hubo una
medida una orientación política que fue
cueste lo que cueste es decir que
Cuántos países en el mundo hubiesen
querido beneficiar del apoyo para las
empresas para los alargados del Estado
para que no se pierda el poder de de
vida mientras estábamos en eso Entonces
obviamente no se puede ya más usar ese
ese esa disposición financiera porque el
dinero no es obviamente gratuito Y por
cierto los países y en este caso Francia
tiene que pagar
el dinero que gastó y que gastó de
manera legitima con él la covid entonces
hoy en día las reformas Por cierto
tienen que tienen que hacerse claro
usted nos Explica las razones de fondo
por la que El Ejecutivo hizo prevalecer
esta reforma a las pensiones y las
formas legislativas que utilizó y
constitucionales que utilizó para
hacerlo florián ustedes está de acuerdo
Yo sé que está contestado incluso por
parte de la izquierda yo no soy parte de
los que lo contestan porque de hecho hay
que reconocer que cada partido que fue
en un lugar de la oposición critica el
cuarenta y nueve tres y una vez que está
en el poder lo utiliza y como muy bien
lo lo ha dicho el Pascal fue utilizado
por todos los partidos políticos sin
excepción y fue utilizado un montón de
veces 100 veces
seguramente el cuarenta y nueve tres es
para desbloquear situaciones de
bloqueada Entonces es necesario y es una
herramienta que no es antidemocrática en
el sentido que de todas formas el
parlamento siempre va a tener la última
palabra el El Ejecutivo va a poner en
riesgo su responsabilidad accionando el
49 3 y entonces el parlamento tiene que
votar A favor o en contra del ejecutivo
Y si vota en contra del Ejecutivo en
este momento la ley se no puede ser
votada no está validada y El Ejecutivo
tiene que renunciar y el gobierno entero
entonces la última palabra siempre está
a favor del parlamento eso es importante
y un un una precisión más este cuarenta
y nueve tres está efectivamente limitado
a los proyectos de leyes Fiscales
presupuestariales como lo estamos yendo
ahorita más uno que es para cualquier
proyecto de ley por año de legislatura
bueno Esto fue todo lo todo el debate
que suscitó esta reforma la gran
pregunta ahora es que viene a
continuación el gobierno de Manuel bajó
tal como lo dijo el presidente en su
alocución espera una nueva hoja de ruta
con tres Pilares fundamentales y una
acción pronta en 100 días mientras que
los sindicatos se rehúsan a sentarse a
negociar los siete las seis medidas que
el consejo constitucional tumbó de la
reforma y que incluyen por ejemplo mayor
empleabilidad de las personas mayores de
50 años entre otros los sindicatos dicen
que no se sentarán a negociar con El
Ejecutivo hasta las marchas del primero
de mayo mientras que macron los convocó
a reunirse el 18 de abril que sigue
entonces ahora Pascal un cambio de ya
superar las pensiones y pasar a los
temas que propone el gobierno macron o
seguir debatiendo las pensiones como lo
esperan los sindicatos
bueno como como bien dijo primero el
Primero de Mayo es dentro de dos semanas
Ah entonces
si la expresión democrática significa
Pues que siga sigan manifestaciones y
demostraciones pues así será porque el
derecho de manifestar es un derecho aquí
en Francia
solamente deseamos que no haya tanta
violencia como puede haber con unos
grupos que intentaron desbordar el
movimiento Cívico primero segundo pero
lo dijo Emmanuel hay esos tres Pilares
pero son Pilares que significan la
búsqueda de un contrato social ahora
eso no se decide
uno con sí mismo eso se decide en
concertación Entonces vamos a ver
veremos en los días que vienen digo en
las semanas y dejamos pasar el primero
de mayo pero tarde o temprano Es cierto
que todos los actores que fuesen los
sindicatos que fuesen del representantes
del poder ejecutivo que fuesen actores
políticos parlamentarios etcétera Por
cierto se va a tener que reanudar un
diálogo pero pasará en el momento en el
cual el tiempo político va a permitir
esa reconexión
necesaria para nuestra vida democrática
eso creo que es
importante y fue también Pues un poco lo
que dijo Emmanuel no convocó dijo que la
puerta están abiertas a partir de para
que los actores Pues con los actores
pueda haber ese diálogo que haga avanzar
un proyecto de unidad rehusando Ah las
palabras
del presidente francés Gloria Newton qué
opina cree como Pascal que vendrá un
diálogo o seguirá la división en Francia
no Bueno hay dos cosas primero el
historial que hay entre
responsabilidades de sindicato
reformista y el presidente macron se
conocían cuando el presidente macron era
ministro de economía y ya el contacto
era difícil entre los dos no se
entendían era muy complicado hoy en día
Cuando veamos la falta de diálogo social
que tuvimos sobre el tema de la Reforma
de las pensiones parece un poco una
contradicción después de tantas
tensiones y de tan poco diálogo decir
ahora sí vamos a la mesa todos y vamos a
discutir vamos a dialogar y vamos a
impulsar nuevas reformas Me parece muy
complicado y
poniéndose en la posición de los
sindicatos Tampoco yo iría porque es muy
difícil decir bueno
Admito Mi fracaso Entonces no he logrado
Cancelar esta ley no hubo ya luego
social y entonces voy a dar la razón al
presidente yendo a una
negociación sobre tal o tal punto me
pongo nada más en los zapatos de este
responsable sindical tomando en cuenta
el historial largo que estos dos tienen
no después Está también el tema de la
movilización social la movilización
Social es verdad ha bajado un poco por
las sanaciones que había explicado un
poquito antes por la inflación Quizás
por el cansancio social también de la
gente pero yo creo que la frustración
social sigue manteniéndose a un nivel
muy alto y la gente sigue apoyando el
movimiento de oposición a las pensiones
a un nivel muy alto hubo un sondeo hoy
que lo lo pone a un 80% de rechazo hacia
este esta reforma de las pensiones
Entonces el escenario que podríamos
tener es o de un lado una movilización
que disminuye por el cansancio social o
una frustración social que sigue
aumentando y con la voluntad de llegar a
un escenario tal cual lo en 2006 que era
el escenario del CP que era un contrato
que se quiso imponer Y qué fracaso y
nunca fue aplicado a pesar del grupo
discúlpame lo interrumpo porque antes de
terminar que se nos acaba el tiempo les
quiero hacer una pregunta muy corta
ustedes creen entonces que vendrán
reformas dentro del gabinete de macron
Empezando por la primera ministra
Elizabeth sí o no Comenzando por florear
Bueno para mí sí pero después de los
indios y
bueno
vendrán definitivamente
me parece obvio
e indispensable que hayan reformas sobre
muchos sectores que fuesen sociales pero
también vimos oímos la temática de la
inmigración en la locución del del
presidente es decir pues un en el marco
de de búsqueda de una nueva coherencia
nacional sí miremos entonces y ya
miramos entonces cómo esta reforma las
pensiones que ahora es ley creada todo
un debate de lo que está por venir en
Francia si habrá o no el diálogo social
que está promoviendo macron o si
continúa la frustración social como nos
lo dicen nuestros invitados Pascal tuvo
analista internacional Gracias por estar
con nosotros y lo mismo gracias aflojean
la fax Vocero del partido federación
progresista a ustedes Muchas gracias por
acompañar nos y a quienes nos sintonizan
en el debate de France 24 Gracias
también por estar con nosotros En nombre
del equipo técnico la producción del
programa estuvo a cargo de Laura garzón
y de Giovanni agudelo y la producción de
invitados a cargo de Tania Herrera Los
invito a que sigan dejando todos sus
comentarios y preguntas en las redes
sociales ya que continúen con más en
France 24
[Música]